from the LA Times
interesting case
I'm not really interesting at all but
we're going to talk about it uh Fast and
Furious star Tyrese Gibson is taking
Home Depot to court accusing the Home
Improvement chain of discrimination and
racial profiling so
in a lawsuit here's the case okay he was
discriminated against and racially
profiled at a Home Depot
and the moment you think you hear that
you might think like at a Home Depot
the discrimination at a Home Depot
that usually I mean any Home Depot I've
been to pretty pretty diverse
so just not exactly what you would
expect to encounter that kind of thing
um
and it gets even more uh surprising when
you realize that the other two people
who are discriminated against allegedly
one of them's name is Eric Mora and the
other one is Manuel Hernandez so we're
supposed to believe
that Hispanic people are being
discriminated against at Home Depot
um
which is also which is also
a little bit surprising so the core of
the lawsuit is a February 11th incident
in which Home Depot clerks allegedly
purposely interfered with a and with and
refused to process a transaction by
Gibson Maura and Hernandez based on
their skin color and the Craftsman's
national origin
okay so that's what they're saying
oh uh Gibson went in with these two
Mexican guys
and you try to buy some stuff
and apparently but based on what I'm
reading so far
he was told by the store clerk he was
told by the cashier oh we can't process
this why can't you process it uh because
you're black because you're black and
they're Mexican get the hell out we
don't serve your kind here at Home Depot
that happens at Home Depot all the time
very common very common occurrence
uh so is that what happened here we'll
keep reading according to legal
documents Gibson and his two Associates
were purchasing items for a home
improvement project but the checkout
process took longer due to a glitch in
the system while an unidentified
employee was rescanning the items fans
began to notice Gibson who stepped out
of store to avoid creating disturbance
the lawsuit says that Gibson informed
the employee that Maura and Hernandez
would complete the purchase with his
credit card
uh the cashier acknowledged Gibson and
said he understood the lawsuit says
Gibson asked the cashier if the cashier
needed anything further from him to
complete the transaction the cashier
said no and that Gibson could leave
after Gibson left the cashier refused to
complete the transaction with Maureen
Hernandez despite Gibson again
authorizing the transaction via FaceTime
video calls document says Gibson
returned to the store and complete the
transaction only after heated
discussions with the cashier the actor
also asked to speak to the store's
manager who alleged to refuse to speak
with Gibson in person
um the lawsuit says quote this is a
clear and deplorable instance of
discriminatory mistreatment and consumer
racial profiling the treatment of Gibson
Mora and Hernandez by the Home Depot was
humiliating and demeaning
so that's it that's what happened they
he was trying to buy something he wanted
to step out of the store and still have
the the thing processed and the cashier
originally according to him the cash
originally said yeah you can do that but
then he left and the cashier said
actually I can't process unless he's
here and so it's kind of inconvenient
and that's it that's all that happened
and from that they're extrapolating that
uh that Home Depot is discriminating
against against blacks and Mexicans
which by the way like if Home Depot were
were to refuse to provide service to
Hispanic people they would be they would
go out of business in 45 minutes they
they wouldn't be able to it's like
saying that Cinnabon is discriminating
against obese people like that's your
whole that's most of your clientele uh
so that doesn't make a lot of sense but
here's what we see here
it it this is this is a a good example
of the racism framework that I'm always
talking about where if you have the
left's racism framework
uh and you're black or you're in an
approved victim group
then every mild inconvenience will be
understood based on it so it's real it's
more of a lens I suppose than a
framework framework makes it sound more
uh intellectual than it really is it's
just a lens
and this is the lens through which they
view the world
and the lens says that like that uh your
your blacks you're a victim uh everyone
automatically is racist against you
because you're black and so therefore
it's just anything that happens to you
that you don't like is because of racism
nobody needs to say anything that
indicates it or anything like that it's
just
it happened to you you don't like it
you're black therefore it is racist and
that is that is as far as it goes that
is that is as um complex as the equation
gets
uh if you're looking through the racism
lens
which which also
makes it
the more that you keep these these
glasses on the more that you look at the
world through this lens
um it's like the more detached from
reality you become
where you lose any grip on on just like
human nature and understanding how the
world works
because those of us who are not wearing
those lenses
we hear a story like this and we think
like yeah that's how it goes to these
places
you go in and you know you're told One
Thing by One customer service guy and
then it doesn't work and then you want
to talk to a manager and the manager
it's like this is just this is how it
goes
or if they're if you go to one of these
places
and there's like a slight wrinkle
there's a slight complication you want
to do something that's like a little bit
outside of the norm and in this case he
wants to process the transaction while
he walks outside it's just like a slight
wrinkle and that breaks down the whole
system and mostly because you're dealing
with a you know a cashier who's like a
17 year old kid who has no idea what's
going on and doesn't care
and um no one is really invested in what
they're doing
nobody actually cares about you as a
customer but that's that's the case for
all of us this is the boat we're all in
and if you don't have the racism lenses
on then you just understand that okay
yeah that's that's life that's how it
works at these places it's like we all
experience that
of course if you see it that way then
you can't make your uh
what is it going for a million dollars
you know Tyrese Gibson he's a star Fast
and Furious which a franchise that
somehow has made you know 75 trillion
dollars at the box office he needs
another million from Home Depot to
assuage his his deep emotional suffering
of course if you'd like to see what else
I have to say you can access my full
show by going to dailywire.com or by
going to the Matt Walsh Show Twitter
page hope to see you there Godspeed